neural efficiency is an aspect of
strength of performance that often goes
overlooked
however it is absolutely critical if you
want to be able to use your strength in
a practical setting
and it does absolute wonders for agility
too let's see why neural efficiency
may be the missing link in your training
and how it relates to
fascia and dynamical systems theory
to result in virtuous dynamic
coordinated demonstrations of strength
and power
the mistake many make with functional
training is to train muscle groups in
isolation
the belief is that if you strengthen all
the muscles that are used in a
particular movement
then the individual will be able to
perform that movement with more strength
in reality this is not always the case
the example we have often given on this
channel
is the martial artist who can punch with
significantly more force and power
than a bodybuilder or powerlifter
despite those athletes being ostensibly
stronger
just because the bodybuilder has
stronger pecs dealts and triceps
that doesn't mean they can throw a
powerful punch partly this is because
they may have trained in a less
explosive manner
partly it's because they may have missed
the rotational muscles such as the
obliques and serratus muscles
but on top of that it is because they
haven't trained the muscles together
and in that order the martial artist has
doing this has caused changes in the
martial artists brain
they've repeatedly used the same network
of brain cells that send signals to the
right muscles in the right order
as such those brain cells have become
ingrained through processes such as
myelination
the coating of axons to insulate the
neurons the pattern of activation in the
brain directly corresponds with the
pattern of activation in the body
and for the athlete the signal is
stronger and much more efficient
there is less overspill to neighboring
areas meaning that only the useful
muscles are activated
helping to relax antagonistic forces and
reduce energy expenditure
and more muscle fibers are recruited in
the relevant muscles
this is neural efficiency in motor skill
and it correlates with strength
agility speed and general performance
this then raises a question
for the functional athlete is the bench
press the most useful movement they
could perform
let's consider a wrestler for a moment
or a rugby player these are athletes
that are required to push opponents
benchpress develops muscles useful for
horizontal pushing so it's great right
well here's the issue when you push a
person or an object in real life
you don't push them while lying flat on
your back instead you push while
standing up
this requires strength in your core
particularly the rectus abdomini
which works to provide anti-extension so
your back doesn't just bend over
backwards
if you're pushing with one arm you'll
also need to engage the obliques to
prevent twisting too you'll also need to
drive power through the legs
and you'll use proprioceptors the
sensing cells of your muscles
to understand how much force you can
deliver before falling over
your body is performing complex maths
that you aren't even aware of
to keep you upright and deliver power in
the right places
all of this factors into that mental
model
this is important and often overlooked
when it comes to virtuous powerful
movement
perception is tied to that movement in
this case the multifidus muscles that
run up and down the spine
are particularly dense with muscle
spindles that sense changes in muscle
length
their job is often to prepare the body
for incoming movements
this contributes to the individual's
perceptual motor landscape
that is to say that the movement pattern
must alter to accommodate the
information coming into the brain
lying flat on a bench removes those
important data points
providing an incomplete model to work
with a martial artist sees how important
the perceptual input is to the motor
pattern
when they block a punch without thinking
the same thing happens as we learn to
catch our balance when we fall
here the input is visual and
proprioceptive it's unhelpful to think
of any of these signals as separate
we must marry the information coming
through our eyes with the position of
our head
communicated to us by the spindles in
our neck and in order to push with power
from an upright position you also need
to practice reacting to the equal and
opposite forces
by stabilizing yourself in response to
signals from your muscle spindles
and golgi tendon organs so what happens
if you develop
extremely powerful pecs and shoulders
without the core to support them
and what if you aren't able to transfer
that power to a real pushing movement
because you've never practiced doing it
you've lost resolution in your motor
perception
you're movement blind the good news is
that if you're performing a lot of skill
training and you're using strength
training to back this up you will have
the benefit of both components
i'm not saying then that one type of
training is better than the other or
that there is no place for weightlifting
movements or isolation movements
in building a more performant individual
after all we can't build as much
strength in the pecks or shoulders
specifically
when standing up because of the
bottleneck presented by the core and
unstable position i'm just saying you
need both
the issue is when you only perform bench
press and expect this to mean you can
start pushing things around like the
juggernaut
you will lack not only the core
stability but also the coordination and
neural efficiency to transfer
all of that available strength into the
target that's why those interested in
real world performance
should utilize movements like the cable
press band press
cable punch out sled push even car push
there's another potential way in which
the body adapts to the demands placed on
it over time
and it's rather fascinating or
fascinating
you could say
fascia is the thin film-like structure
that helps keep our organs and other
structures in place
it wraps around everything and through
its dispersed tension called tensegrity
it helps to maintain our structure and
absorb impacts
we now know that the fascia is also
extremely dense with nerves
both proprioceptive and interoceptive
this full body cat suit helps us to form
a mental model of ourselves
and to move gracefully through space
moreover it also contains muscle cells
that may actually contribute to force
production and what's really interesting
is the way it seems to join disparate
muscles working towards a singular goal
this is called myofascial force
transmission and it may help us to
better coordinate muscles that work
together
for greater force production like they
were one muscle
the next part comes as no surprise once
you recognize the incredible
adaptability
of the human body the fascia is capable
of remodeling itself
in response to training and
environmental factors which may in turn
alter the way different muscle groups
work together
constantly use muscle a with muscle b
and they may eventually become
physically linked as well as
neurologically according to tom myers
author of anatomy trains
fibroblast cells act like the architects
of the fascial system
traveling through it and producing
collagen and other chemicals needed to
reinforce it as required
perform the same movements over and over
and your body will redesign itself to
perform that movement
however if you perform the movement too
precisely you may find you struggle to
vary that movement significantly
as you can see then we have these two
powerful systems potentially adapting
both to one another
and the environment around them that's
not to mention all the other systems
that adapt and respond in a similar
manner
from fiber type composition to tendon
hysteresis
to fiber thickness all self-organizing
around the goal
the organism and the environment and
this is where psychology graduates may
be raising their hands
what i'm describing here is the dynamic
systems theory of motor learning
as described by esther ellen this is
also sometimes referred to as dynamical
systems theory
the key phrase here is self organizing
this is the term often used to
illustrate the way that multiple systems
within the body
are able to adapt to the demands placed
on them in dynamic systems theory these
demands are called constraints
and are usually listed as organism
environment
task or goal in other words the precise
mechanics of a movement are the result
of the individual's goals and
environment
as much as their own movement patterns
and biological features
a good coach should understand this and
seek to create interventions that rely
on all three factors
often this is achieved through the use
of external cues rules and tasks
that reframe the drills that the athlete
participates in squatting becomes
squatting while throwing and catching a
medicine ball
these are referred to as teaching games
for understanding keep in mind that a
lot of what we've discussed here is
theoretical
dynamic systems theory is just one
theory in a sea of models of motor
learning
i'll discuss more in future likewise
fascia is a very hot topic right now
but it is an area that requires a lot
more research before it should inform
training decisions to a large degree
traditionally facial remodeling is not
discussed in the context of these motor
learning models
but i've attempted to connect the dots
here so take all this as conjecture
that said there is certainly enough
evidence and enough logical argument to
say that we need
varied and challenging movement in order
to develop true coordination
neural efficiency and functional
performance these ideas should be
married with tried and true training
methods
yes use squats and isolation movements
to build stronger legs but also practice
using those legs as part of the larger
system
running jumping and pushing use rote
repetition to master movements like
kicks
throws and lifts once you've reached a
certain level of expertise
introduce the unexpected perform the
movement on a hill
use a different form of resistance stand
on one leg or get someone to throw
something at you
train with cables sandbags medicine
balls kettlebells and club bells
these also have the benefit of creating
movements that are slightly different
every time you perform them this is what
is sometimes described as repetition
without repetition
a term coined by soviet
neurophysiologist nikolai bernstein
in other words a basketball player
should not just practice shooting hoops
from a comfortable static position
they should also practice shooting those
hoops from the wrong leg while being
jostled or when tired as described by
general motor program and schemer theory
this can help to form more robust mental
models movement patterns that are more
broadly generalizable
to a variety of different situations
interestingly
this is an argument slightly against
bruce lee's 1000 kicks
though to be clear there is definitely
benefit to rote repetition
particularly during the learning phase
again it's about combining methods
try not to view your mind and body as
separate entities recognize the role of
perception and goals in defining
movement
turn training into play be mindful of
your senses and keep the body guessing
all this will also help to keep your
body more plastic and changeable
the more you learn the better you become
at learning and all genetic differences
aside
if you give two people the same training
program it is the most plastic athlete
that will develop the most impressive
performance
i hope you found this video useful
interesting guys if you did then please
leave a like and share around that helps
me out immensely
comment down below and let me know what
you think about all this do you
incorporate challenges like that into
your own training
how are you going to apply these ideas
during workouts subscribe if you want
much more like this
and if you want a training program an
ebook that's designed around this kind
of philosophy then be sure to check out
super functional training
in the description down below that's my
ebook and training program
and there's a big discount on right now
whilst we're in lockdown hope you guys
are all keeping safe thanks so much for
watching this one
and i'll see you next time bye
for now